I'm going to talk to you about how to
understand and apply innovation
strategies in two organizations so I
want to talk to you about management
innovation techniques if standard
management techniques budgeting human
resource management performance
measurement and so on in the case of
innovation we talked about strategic
planning which is also by the way a
standard management tool it actually
crosses both fields the way we've
defined it re-engineering quality
management benchmarking team management
and outsourcing and we'll spend a whole
week on outsourcing itself so
sustainability management and innovation
innovation is about creative management
that makes organizations more agile
effective and efficient sounds nice
right improving the sustainability of an
operation is difficult due to the
persistence of short-term thinking so
part of what you're trying to do as an
innovator in sustainability is bring
about a longer-term perspective the need
for immediate results and the lack of
understanding of how sustainability can
actually help an organization's bottom
line leads to opposition also the
persistence of standard operating
procedures once people learn how to do
something and they are reluctant to
change it because always worked in the
data farm example that you heard before
people that run data centers like
redundancy they like extra energy use
because the only real sanction they have
is a thing breaks and doesn't work so if
it cost a lot of money and energy to
keep it running that's ok
organizations have what I call
organizational gravity which is that
even if you have a period of creative
innovation and sort of this little lift
to the organization
eventually it sort of regresses back to
perhaps not the old way but a new old
way of doing things because people get a
little tired of change they like to show
up at work get their coffee do the same
routine that they do every other day and
they don't like it when somebody says
we're not
challenging environment got to change
things frequently you know it's
uncomfortable it's annoying
who needs it okay but in the world we're
in it's inevitable and of course these
sustainability issues are going to be
challenges for a long time now I often
talk about management as a craft and not
a science and what I mean by that is why
do we have two groups give presentations
of the same case if there's a right
answer because there is no right answer
it's a craft one person crafts a
solution that works in some settings and
not in another a crafts person might
make a very comfortable chair for one
person the next person who gives them a
backache okay that's what a crafts about
trying to figure it out for the
situation you're in now in the cake and
the course of the semester we looked at
management tools one at a time we looked
at sustainability issues one at a time
but in fact when you solve problems in
the real world they come at you all the
time and you don't get to choose which
tool are which are which issue you have
to deal with you have to simply respond
and frame your response to what's
happening in front of you you don't get
to do it you know one strategy at a time
you have to use them in combination and
so for some of what we're doing in a
class is always a little bit artificial
so when I think about management
innovation our tools in general I think
about tools that influence an
organization's environment tools that
influence an organization's people tools
for managing the organization's
financial resources and tools for
influencing the organization's
operations those are the kinds of things
that we are either trying to keep intact
or or to change so when you think about
the environment
you've got strategic planning you've got
outsourcing and leveraging partnerships
and you have political management
advertising trying to change the
environment by the message
you send to it for the organization's
people you have the overall field of
human resource management you have
communications interpersonal relations
meetings conflict resolution networking
and all of those kinds of things for
managing the organization's financial
resources you have to think about
revenues and budgeting and tracking
resources and integrating financial with
other indicators and then when you think
about the operations of an organization
you have the development and
communication of standard operating
procedures remember standard operating
procedures the basics of Management
preformed responses to specific stimuli
then you use organization structure who
works for who then you have benchmarking
looking at other organizations and what
they do then you have performance
management and measurement simply trying
to figure out what the organization is
doing to see whether your changes have
any impact crisis management sometimes
you have to respond quickly to things
that are thrown at you by your
environment quality and operations
management that's where you analyze look
how we do work around here what are the
actual processes for communicating with
our suppliers focusing on our own
operation and focusing on our customers
and then re-engineering when do we knock
the whole thing down and start again so
what's the concept of sustainability
management innovation well the 21st
century we see society in the economy
rapidly changing in response to new
technologies the pace of organizational
change the pressure on public and
private organizations is growing
innovation is needed then because of
this pace economic technological social
and cultural and political changes
accelerating the political cycles are
now measured in months rather than in
decades the technological innovations
are coming at us at a rapid pace this
accelerated rate of change has
challenged the traditional bureaucratic
Four
of organization the way that we did
things in the past which was basically
stable steady and slow stable steady and
slow doesn't work anymore because the
environment were in is none of those
things we are in a global economy that
is rapidly changing that is creating
political and economic pressure that
organizations have to respond to and so
that's part of why we're talking about
innovation tonight organizations have to
change rapidly to keep pace with the
changes in their environment what does
that mean they need to develop standard
operating procedures more quickly they
need to take new technologies and put
them in to place more quickly think
about the first time you well maybe
maybe you can't remember but the first
time that you used a windows-based
computer and you move from das based
computers if you were a PC person it was
like you know and then every 18 months
there was some other innovation yet to
relearn what you're doing you might get
used to one form of Excel one form of
word before you know if there's another
one and then there's another one and you
get comfortable in one you don't even
like the changes but you better get
responding to it in a sense that's a
metaphor for how the economy is changing
organizations it's really the same thing
so you have to the technologies come in
staff has to learn new ways of doing
things new demands are made on people
networks of organizations are replacing
the old vertically integrated
hierarchies the company you know the I
think I spoke in this class about Ford
Motor Company the traditional hierarchy
vertically integrated organization
controlled every aspect of production
now I had lunch with the guys that are
doing the Nissan Leaf and this car is
led by a multinational management team
it's being built in Georgia with a 1.2
billion dollar subsidy from the
Department of Energy of stimulus money
and for one of the first times in
Nissan's history
the new product is not being dominated
by Japanese management so and it's being
made by components from several hundred
different organizations all have to be
coordinated and integrated and brought
to the assembly line without huge
warehouses you know holding on to all of
these parts as it's manufactured
national boundaries are less important
now than they once were organizations
corporations exist in multiple countries
and buy and sell in multiple countries
International Cooperation is becoming
more important because of the global
economy and the global media but just
the same sovereignty is still a powerful
political force in our world and
nation-states are still incredibly
important and so we have this economic
and technological world that is global
but we have a political world that's not
and that creates problems for trade but
it also creates problems for
sustainability a lot of organizational
reform efforts fail partially it's
because people try to throw things
together before they've thought them
through and partially it's resistance to
change in organizations the other thing
is that these innovation strategies I'm
going to talk about people think about
them is independent cure-alls so we do
TQM we do reengineering we do
benchmarking whatever the the mantra at
the moment is in fact you need to do all
of these kinds of things you need to
understand all of these innovation tools
because they are only useful in
different situations consulting firms in
particular oversell whatever it is
they've developed so there's lots and
lots of examples of consulting firms you
know who by the way are not always
rewarded for solutions but they're but
they build by the hour that's an
argument for complexity you know because
it takes more time successful innovation
in my view is often incremental and
small-scale you try something you see if
it works then you build on that you try
something else
each organization is different and faces
different situations and particular
points of time and so there is no
one-size-fits-all there is no management
magic bullet every and whenever you hear
somebody tell you there is one that they
found the answer ask them how much they
charge so what are the key issues that
innovation innovators have to address
well the first one is how well do we
know the basics of organization what do
we do around here okay
what's the basics of Columbia University
what does Columbia University do anybody
here work for Columbia okay so what does
Columbia do yeah what do we do here
okay I would argue we do two things what
do you think we do yes those are our two
main product lines right education and
research we create new knowledge right
and we disseminate knowledge okay so
it's pretty simple right so let's look
at this classroom okay is it comfortable
and can you hear everything you you guys
are all saying sort of sometimes can you
see each other so it sorta sometimes
what if this room was banked and
semicircular and each of you had a
little microphone at a table with an
outlet for your computer
sounds good huh okay so right to lee
bollinger care of low library and tell
them that we want that classroom okay so
you can imagine improvements let's put
it that way but that's what I'm driving
at here you know Columbia is very good
at these things actually we're very good
at education we're very good at research
we're one of the best places in the
world for those things okay but even
this place is struggling to keep pace
with the time and with the technology
right so whatever organization you
analyze you have to ask yourself what do
we do around here how can we improve
what we're doing around here okay why do
we do course evaluations in these
classes
because I want to know what you think
why do I do exams because I want to know
what you know okay why do we measure
performance
now it's an imperfect process though
right I mean we've talked about that in
the first hour how imperfect these
indicators are but you have to have some
metrics so the question you have to ask
as you approach innovation is who is our
customers and what do they want is
that's how you define quality now in the
case of a student in a school you're not
just a customer are you I mean I hate to
say this to you but you're also a
product okay because when you go out you
are somebody that this university
produced as an educated person and and
this is sort of unique in the customer
service business most of the people that
want to buy what Columbia has to offer
aren't allowed to we have this thing
called an admissions process okay if you
go to the Honda dealership there's no
admissions process you give them your
money buy your Honda okay in the Masters
and sustainability management the MPA
environmental science and policy or
Cephas degree more people most of the
people that want to come and be
customers aren't allowed to we turn them
down so it's an interesting question
when you think about the person is a
customer on the other hand I want to
think about the student as a customer
because that's part of a dimension of
the student is I want to make sure that
I'm effective that my programs are
effective in educating them and they're
the only people who can really tell you
whether or not something is working okay
now their employers will tell you also
if something worked but while you're
here I need to know what you're thinking
so that's something that I need to know
and then you know do we value in the
organization creativity and
out-of-the-box thinking or not you know
Columbia University has been here since
1754 it predates the United States of
America it has established a great group
of traditions that provide that brand
name that makes people want to come here
and so some of that is actually because
of
resistance to change if you go to
Columbia College the FMT call the
Columbia core curriculum which is the
same core curriculum they've had for
over a century why because they think
that that's fundamental to education at
the same time last year they let us set
up this program in sustainability
management ten years ago they let us set
up an MTA in environmental science and
policy so they'll allow new things but
they also have some resistance to change
so an organization that's been around
for a while has to have core values it
doesn't want to change just for its own
sake but it has to be open to it so
those are some of the issues that
innovators have to face one of the
issues that a manager has to face when
they do innovation is when should we
accept the high organizational cost of
radical change top-down let's just redo
the whole thing it doesn't work anymore
then there's the make or buy decision
when should we have a contract to do
this because it's not central to what we
do when has the organization's
environment changed so much that we have
to change our mission or focus in our
strategy in order to survive when should
we use groups to do work instead of
individuals those are issues that
innovators have to ask so let me go
through a bunch of these innovation
tools to find them talk about how they
work in and what their advantages and
disadvantages are starting with
strategic planning a strategy delineates
the resources that are used to pay for
specific activities designed to
accomplish specific objectives resources
activities objectives how does it work
well typically you start the
organization thinking about who are we
what do we do and what are the goals
we're going to need in order to generate
resources strategic planning requires an
organization to look at itself top-down
it can be used to help build a sense of
identity and mission within the
organization it can also keep an
organization from rapidly moving from
one side to the next
depending on the priorities of the
moment
a strategy can actually be an argument
against being overly opportunistic
something comes up and you say no we
said we're going to do X so we're not
going to do Y today because otherwise
we'll never get X done and and that's a
benefit of strategic planning the cost
takes a lot of time and resources to do
it
sometimes the organization gets caught
in a political and symbolic battle
around its strategy and sometimes and
this is one of the more interesting
parts of a strategic planning by saying
what you're going to do you also say
what you're not going to do and that can
then generate political opposition
internal opposition from the people who
want to do the things you've decided not
to do because it means you set
priorities okay the second one is
re-engineering and this is basically
starting over and saying we're going to
do this differently how do you do this
you identify the steps that add value
you eliminate the steps that don't add
value and you redesign work processes to
emphasize speed quick turnaround and so
forth that's reengineering it's not easy
to do and very often you have entrenched
interest in an organization that will
fight it and then the other problem is
while you're re-engineering who's
dealing with the customers who's
collecting the money who's keeping the
organization alive that's why this is a
high-risk strategy in the private sector
you've seen instance of this often
accompanied before or after a lot of
layoffs in the public sector it's often
a reorganization we create a new
organization so in New York City the
human resources administration used to
deal with the foster care program which
is when children are taken away from
their parents because they're abusive or
their parents die and they have to find
another set of parents for them that's
foster care okay
used to be done by HRA now it's done by
the agency a separate agency that
focuses on children specifically why did
they set that up they set it up because
the little girl got killed by her
parents and Rudy Guiliani needed
political cover and they created a new
age
see scopetta who Benchley became the
fire commissioner in New York was the
first Commissioner and they developed a
whole new set of standard operating
procedures about how to deal with these
children that was an example of
reengineering in the public sector but
it's a high-risk strategy and it can
disrupt the organization it's often done
in desperation it's often done when
organizations have no choice because the
thing is so dysfunctional
you simply can't keep going they then
there's total quality management of
quality management this is one that I
actually worked on for about 15 years I
liked it a lot as a fundamental of
management and let me just describe the
process because it can get pretty
complicated but I actually can make it
fairly simple for you the first thing is
you work with your suppliers to make
sure the supplies you get fit well in
your production process and by
communicating with suppliers you can
improve the quality of what you produce
and let me give you a very simple
example of two simple examples one in
manufacturing so let's say I'm a blue
jean manufacturer and I have three
different kinds of blue jeans and the
cotton comes into my factory in one
truck and I have the the factory set up
to do say khaki first stone wash second
and regular denim third okay but the
stuff comes in on the truck and it's
randomly packaged in other words I've
got a couple of boxes of this couple
boxes that so the first thing I have to
do when the boxes get in is I've got to
take them to a big area and I got to
sort them in the order that I'm going to
use them in my factory what if I talk to
my manufacturer and say here's the order
I want you to load this in your truck
they got to load the truck anyway and
they can't follow your direction but if
I don't communicate to them they don't
know that's what I want they don't know
that that's my definition of quality but
if I do I can save a lot of labor and
unloading that truck service example you
get a spreadsheet from somebody with the
financial analysis the first thing I to
do is redefine the categories because
they don't fit into what your boss wants
what if you communicate with the guy who
sends you the spread
saying here's the categories I really
need ok that's communicating with your
suppliers ok so that's the first part of
quality management communicating with
suppliers the second part is continued
analysis continuous analysis of work
processes to improve their functions ok
so you look at how do we do this work
here but you know we set up for a
meeting and we always do these six
things and these six things there's
often a delay in one of them the guy
with the coffee never shows up on time
ok or there's something else in the
production process where there's always
an error or a breakdown so you look at
the error and the break then you say can
we do this any better is there a better
way for us to do this classic example
from thus annotate from the parks
department parks department does two
major things they mow lawns and they
pick up garbage
so Parks Department guys pick up the
garbage they get their dumpster filled
they drive to the dump this is back in
the old days when we had a dump and they
don't mind because when they get to the
dump it's 4:00 in the afternoon and
there's a long line of trucks they get
to hang out and have coffee for an hour
and a half while they're waiting to dump
the garbage
sometimes for 3 hours ok nice for them
not great for the department because
they're paying them to sit around and
wait for the dump ok so what's the
solution
thus annotate the parks department had
been invested in dumpsters so now these
guys don't get to go to the dump anymore
they dump the garbage into the dumpsters
and then at 3 in the morning another
truck comes and brings the dumpster to
the to the dump ok much less labor much
more efficient and analysis of the
process showed here's where the delays
they pick up the garbage fast then they
sit at the dump for three hours ok every
production process has these kinds of
features to it ok so that's the work
process analysis and the third part is
close communication with customers to
identify and understand what they want
and how they define quality quality is
not necessarily what the expert thinks
it is it's what the customer thinks it
is and so you
work to figure out what does my customer
want and lining those up is what quality
management is all about by doing those
kinds of things you can improve the
management of an organization and keep
them open to organizational change
because they're always talking about
suppliers they're always talking to
their customers and always thinking
about how the work gets done one of the
biggest problems organizations is that
very often people accept the supplies as
a given okay this stuff always comes to
us broken there's nothing I can do about
okay or there's always a delay in this
part of the process there's nothing I
can do about it but what you do in TQM
is you get the workers the people who do
the work to sit down together and try to
figure out how do we overcome those
obstacles to production what you want to
do with these kinds of processes by the
way is make it just part of how people
think about their work I wouldn't
imagine a project where I didn't talk to
my suppliers didn't think about work
processes didn't think about my
customers the benefits of TQM is that it
allows an organization to tap into the
knowledge that only the workers know in
other words when you're looking at how
work is done in an organization the
workers are the experts at that work
they know what's going on because
they're doing it not the supervisor okay
the worker so how do you get them to
tell you what they know well first of
all if what they know is that something
isn't working well and the boss designed
it you have to convince them that
they're not going to be punished for
telling the truth but this kind of
process is how organizations can change
very effectively on the other hand if
the overall organization strategy is
faulty a TQM can have the effect of
improving the production of the wrong
thing it's like rearranging the deck
chairs on the Titanic okay you know the
ship's going down before we've got the
best-looking chairs okay
benchmarking very simply is going around
the world and looking at other
organizations do what you do and try to
figure out how they do it and to try to
take what they've what they know how to
do and bring it into your organization
I'm not going to go into great detail on
this because we don't really have enough
time
what I'd say is that what you're trying
to do in benchmarking is look at the
best people in the world the people with
the best reputation get them to let you
look at how they're doing it and try to
copy them okay
the benefit of this is it keeps you open
to other models you look at how other
places are doing things so I look at
when I'm very interested in waste
management so I look at other countries
and how they do it because they're
better than the United States is I I was
at a dinner the other night where where
I learned that in Paris they collect the
garbage every day okay
pretty interesting in New York we don't
okay we'll have to leave something for
the rats now benchmarking is a very
low-tech low-cost technique and it
doesn't disrupt organizations okay on
the other hand it can limit your
creativity because if you don't have a
model for what you're trying to do you
might say well it's never been done
before we can't do it that's that's the
one problem with it team management is
simply getting people to learn how to
work together now this is something that
is a kind of technology how do you get
people to work effectively in groups how
do they become good team participants
you guys have been working in groups in
this class although we haven't trained
you to do it part of what you have to
think about is how do I become a good
group participant how do I contribute to
the group and be somebody that are is a
sought after group participant what are
the techniques that are available to me
and there are ways that you can train
yourself the key in group participation
is being self conscious think about how
other people are viewing you in the
organization now in a good team setting
people set ground rules they think about
different roles they meet their work
responsibilities okay clear goals clear
roles communication training and
beneficial team behaviors so that people
know how to act with each other how do I
listen how do I provide feedback how do
I disagree without being disagreeable
though
those are all techniques that are
increasingly important in innovative
organizations the benefit of course of
team processes is that the tasks were
working on are complicated you need a
lot of different kind of disciplines to
get things done
the problem with with teams is that if
the reward system in the organization
that stays individual people will feel
like they're being ripped off I'm
participating in this thing but I see no
benefit for me personally and so it's
important for organizations to develop
some part of their reward system around
the group and around the team itself
when the performance evaluation system
compensation systems are not modified
the teams lose credibility and people
stop participating in it outsourcing is
what I call the make or buy decision
which is really what do we do ourselves
what's central to who we are as an
organization and what are we willing to
have another organization do for us so
at Columbia you know Barnes & Noble runs
the bookstore ok this is a good thing we
used to run the bookstore Barnes & Noble
runs bookstores this is what they do you
know Starbucks makes coffee ok Columbia
does research and education ok not so
good food service it's ok I don't mean
to criticize the food service people but
you know let's put it this way all
things being equal I'm going to a
restaurant on Broadway ok before I go to
the cafeteria right ok I'm going to
Barnes & Noble instead of to the you
know the bookstore run by the University
ok and on and on and on so the make or
buy decision what are we good at on the
other hand I don't want Starbucks to run
the class ok and I don't rely on Barnes
& Noble to run the Lamont observatory
those are things that we do and we do
well and so an organization is to decide
what is it that we're good at that we're
going to invest our
expertise in and we're going to generate
resources from one of the things about
outsourcing is that as information and
communication gets cheaper it gets
easier to do this you know the invention
of barcodes and the invention of the
internet and personal computers and
digital and personal digital devices
makes it possible to be part of a global
network of production for anything you
can imagine okay now there is this issue
of carbon footprint due to
transportation and that's simply an
argument for figuring out better ways of
shipping things with renewable energy
the costs though of outsourcing is you
lose direct control over operations
management you have to rely on a
supplier to provide you with things and
the skills that you obtain by doing
something become lost to the
organization in order to manage
something you have to know something
about it so the person at Columbia who
manages the Barnes & Noble contract they
didn't know something about the book
business or they're going to be taken to
the cleaners okay
Brent Millward who's a management
scholar at the University of Arizona has
written about what he calls the hollow
state where you can outsource so much
and privatize so much that there's no
management capacity left in the
organization that knows how to do
anything and so that can happen an
organization has to maintain enough
capacity to manage their contractors to
manage their vendors to know enough
about how to do it and sometimes they
get a little carried away with the
outsourcing okay so how do you integrate
these all organization innovation starts
with a strategy re-engineering is
innovation strategy that you only do
when your strategy says we've got to
start over again you know
so take the u.s. steel company they
stopped making steel okay take a company
like Calvin
fine Calvin Klein doesn't make clothing
anymore they brand clothing they are a
name they stop making clothing awhile
ago okay organizations do that over time
they just decided that their distinctive
competence was branding and marketing
not manufacturing benchmarking involves
going and looking at other organizations
and quality management is simply
constant focus on what the work is
benchmarking I think should be part of
any effort to innovate within an
organization let's see what other people
do and every organization as they
innovate has to think about what are the
pressures were under what does the
environment look like where are the
resources remember all this is about
generating resources for the
organization so let me conclude and then
we'll see if we can have a discussion of
some of these things innovation tools
and other management tools are the means
that a manager has to influence the
behavior of an organization the
organization is people an environment
are always changing rapid change can
cause stress with an organization so how
do you respond now whether you're trying
to bring sustainability into an
organization or any other kind of change
sustainability is simply a form of
change and innovation in the
organization and you should think about
it the way you would think about any
other innovation in the organization the
pace of change is increasing due to
change in technology and communication
agility creativity and speed are more
important than ever and this is not
going to stop we're going to see more
and more of this as time goes on and
again
issues of water and energy and material
and waste are simply new factors of
organizational life that have to be
brought in with the techniques that any
management innovation requires